with program and the next up is Johnson
week on counting matchings where the
capacity meant ok thanks a lot and thank
you to be buddy to give a talk here um
so before even starting I'm just gonna
quickly say so capacity is something we
already saw today in the sheath fish
noise talk and and I'm gonna use a lot
of kind of similar concepts that he
talked about there and maybe some other
things but I will make one point about
the word counting here so his main goal
was to approximate you know with some
algorithm and mine is gonna be more to
give lower bounds like sort of explicit
lower bounds for certain combinatorial
things the methods I talked about can be
used in certain circumstances to give
approximation algorithms but I'm gonna
kind of wash over that and or give some
references to that sort so you know this
has been talked about already quite a
bit you know this monomer dimer model
and matching so let me just first let me
just first give an outline of what's
gonna happen here so we're first gonna
very briefly go through that we're
talking about how how it relates to the
coefficients the univariate matching
polynomial how you get locked in cavity
just gonna sort of briefly talk about
this as an intro then to sort of why you
might hope to get certain lower bounds
that I'm then going to talk about ok
then I'm going to go through Gert this
capacity method due to Gurewitz and the
main motivating example for that is
going to be trying to give a lower bound
for perfect matchings of regular
bipartite graphs if you're familiar with
Shrivers lower bound this is i'm gonna
give duritz's proof of this bound and
talk about how actually you can sort of
how he also used his proof to get
pounds than this but I'll talk about
that I'm going to talk about the method
in some general way and sort of show you
how his method gives you this bound and
I'm also going to talk about capacity
and this theorem that he has about
capacity that's the main ingredient to
get this
once I'm through that I'm then going to
talk about how you might generalize this
method and how you might generalize this
theorem talk about the method and then
the sort of main application of this is
going to be a new proof of jaguar's
bound for imperfect matchings in this
more general context this is this is not
any result I think that that Peter
talked about today yeah so this is
something besides that things he spoke
about okay so let's let's keep going so
a lot of us know what a matching is it's
some collection of edges where no two
edges kind of touch at the same vertex
and I'm gonna call something a kay
matching if it contains K edges so the
first thing is a three matching that it
two matching okay another term that's
used for these things are monomer dimer
Arrangements where the dimers are the
are the edges and the monomers are the
extra vertices so you can associate a
partition function to these arrangements
and basically the idea is to each edge
you associate some weight to each vertex
you associate a variable and then you
sum over all of these arrangements
multiplying together the weights of each
edge in the arrangement and then the
variables associated to each vertex that
that are not in the dimer so the
monomers and I'm gonna sometimes use
this shorthand where I think we've seen
this a number of a number of speakers
have used this shorthand before where
you have like a vector raised to
something like a vector and it means the
product over kind of the base to the
exponent so the the first you know one
big result associated to this that's
been very important in everything that
we've talked about is due to common leap
and it basically says I mean it's not
written exactly this way but this is
equivalent it says if you take some
positive edge weights and you plug in
some negative weights
then you look at this apollomon on the
berries of the ex you get something
that's real stable okay and real stable
just means that whenever all of your
inputs are in the upper half plane it's
nonzero the original result right it's a
little bit weird to plug in negative
weights here right but the original
result was in terms of positive weights
and it was in terms of right half-plane
stability okay so what why how are we
going to try to use this or how what are
we going to do with this well the point
is somehow that this concept of real
stability has pretty strong connections
to log in cavity and we're gonna try to
exploit this fact to to get some lower
bounds for certain combinatorial things
that's what we're going to try to do
so the first thing I'm gonna I'm gonna
mention which this is also in the paper
of hominin leap the once you have this
kind of real stability property or have
right half-plane stability or whatever
property you have there's a way to turn
this into some kind of univariate
polynomial where each coefficient ends
up being the number of matchings of size
k in the graph okay and it's um I
there's a number of ways to see this but
that that happens to be one way you can
do this and the point is that real
stability of the original polynomial
means that this thing that you get out
at the end only has negative roots okay
it's a little bit weird with this with
this square root but the point is that
in the original polynomial you only have
terms of total even degree and so you
maybe plug in a T everywhere a root T
everywhere and you actually end up with
a polynomial and the thing that you get
at the end of this is like I said this
kind of version of the univariate
matching polynomial where the case
degree term is the number of K matchings
and since you only have negative roots
you get Newton's in a Newton's
inequalities which basically says that
this the sequence of coefficients forms
an ultra long concave sequence so the
point of me going through this is is
this is just to demonstrate one way you
can get some kind of law of concavity
property out of real stability and you
can see how right this is not maybe if I
want some absolute ban on the number of
K matchings of a certain of a graph this
is not that great
just because right somehow this says
that I can get a lower bound on the
number of K matching as if I know
something about the matchings of
slightly different sizes but maybe we
can use some more general version of
this thing or we can sort of generalize
the idea of what it means to be Laughlin
cave and see if we can maybe get
something a little bit different so at
this point then I'm gonna I'm going to
sort of move on beyond that so like I
said can we we get some information on K
mashings so I'll let me get to that in a
second can we get more refined bounds in
these coefficients may be for we're
gonna have to maybe restrict a specific
G because in general getting getting
some bounds
these coefficients is well it's not
certain things are not known but it's
probably well it's going to be a lot
harder so but we're probably have to
restrict a certain G but maybe we can
use some generalization of vlogging
cavity to to figure this out okay I just
want to make a comment here so these
these Newton's and equalities come from
real rootedness but it turns out for
people who have been here for this
semester there's been a lot of talk of
these other polynomials these completely
law concave strongly law cave Lorenzi
and polynomials where you also get these
inequalities and similar things okay
so just just as a as an FYI those of you
who have been around for that
so like I said right let's try to
generalize these logs and cavity
properties we know that real stable
multivariate polynomials have some
properties beyond just these Newton's
inequalities maybe we can use these to
get what we want so I'm going to now
move on kind of in another direction
this was just a sort of maybe set up why
we might expect to have these sort of
log and cavity properties in the
situation that we that we want does
anyone there are any questions before I
kind of move on to the next thing
okay lorenzi and polynomial so Lauren C
and polynomial maybe it is some
generalization of real stable
polynomials which basically says I mean
one one way to characterize them is to
say that if you take any if non-negative
coefficients if you take any directional
derivative in the so let me let me start
over
you have a polynomial with non-negative
coefficients it's log concave in the
positive or that and if you take any
number of directional derivatives in the
positive or --then the thing that you
get back is also log concave in the
positive ortho
so it turns out that these like I mean
it's maybe just from the words I said it
would seem reasonable that these would
have something like like Newton's
inequalities and these turn out to be a
pretty natural generalization of real
stable polynomials that a lot of people
here have have studied okay so then
let's let's shift gears like I said to
and talk about Gerdes approach to this
problem of lower bounding bipartite
perfect matchings okay so so let's let's
say we have some d regular bipartite
graph on 2n vertices okay something like
this here d is 3 and n is 4 okay and you
can construct this bipartite adjacency
matrix by basically associating to each
row one of the vertices on the top and
each column one of the vertices on the
bottom and for instance if you look in
the first row this gives you the
information of which vertices the first
vertex on the top is matched to so all
right it's matched to one two and four
that's why you have ones there
okay and if I'm going to pick out a
perfect matching okay it's hopefully
that red you can see that red it's going
to look something like this so I've
picked the perfect matching over here
okay and I associated to it certain one
entries in this matrix and for it to be
a perfect matching it means that every
vertex on the top will be associated to
it will have one edge coming out of it
every vertex on the bottom will have one
edge coming out of it okay and so that's
going to mean that right every row and
column of this matrix there'll be one
edge there'll be one one that's selected
okay and so what this means is to count
perfect matchings as I'm sure many of
you know it's the same thing as
computing the permanent of this matrix
okay and so we're going to try to get
some bound on this again it's going to
end up being Shrivers bound but we're
gonna we're going to come to it using a
different proof I'm just going to point
out something here that that D
regularity comes into play in the sense
that this matrix has this what I'm going
to call EE D stochastic property which
is a sort of maybe abuse of the word
sarcastic here but it basically means
that the row sums and the column sums
are all deep
so I you know we I don't really need to
explain how this polynomial comes into
play the sheath did did a good job of
talking about why this is related you
basically take you know linear forms
associated each row and you product them
together and the point is that if you
take a bunch of derivatives of this you
end up getting the number of perfect
matches
okay so right so the idea is somehow
then we have this problem that we know
is going to be hard right
this is picking out some particular
coefficient of this polynomial the
polynomial is very easy to write down
and to evaluate but somehow
approximating this code like we should
only be able to approximate this
coefficient we shouldn't be able to
explicitly compute this coefficient
so I just rewrote the the last line we
had there okay so and some more
information about this polynomial that
we have right the thing that's going to
link up to these log concavity
properties at the end of the day is the
fact that this polynomial is real stable
this is easy to see because if a IJ are
non-negative numbers then if I plug in
any any very excuse me any elements of
the complex upper half plane into XJ
right each linear form is just going to
be some convex combination of
combination of upper half plane elements
so I'm just going to get a product of
things in the upper half plane which is
always going to be nonzero okay so this
has some real stability property so we
were thinking this is gonna have some
log concavity property and we also know
that this derivative preserves this
property okay
so the fact that the derivative
preserves real stability is it is a
classic result called the Gauss Lucas
theorem and then the fact that plug in
zero preserves it is also very easy to
see there's a there's a chance that
maybe by doing this we're just gonna get
the zero polynomial but we're not really
worried about that let's we'll just
assume that that counts is real stable
even though you know it you know has
zeros everywhere but let's just not
worry about that detail but the idea is
that this is going to set up some nice
inductive structure right the hope is
now right we have some real stability a
real stable polynomial it has some
locking cavity properties we're going to
apply this derivative it's gonna
preserve these logs and cavity
properties and if we can keep track of
something related to logging cavity
along the way right after we apply all n
of these to every variable we're going
to be left with a number that we that we
want to bound okay so this is this is
going to be the general plan okay we're
gonna associate some useful analytic
quantity to this to this polynomial this
particular one and and you know
hopefully to real stable polynomials in
general we're then going to keep track
of exactly how this operator affects the
quantity okay so we apply this operator
hopefully we can get some bound on how
much this thing is going to change okay
and then after we apply this to all the
variables we're going to be left with
the quantity we want to bound and so
right if this all works out in the way
that I'm sort of vaguely saying here
it's gonna be really great because we'll
get end up getting some lower bound
and it turns up this useful analytic
quantity that we're going to analyze and
discuss is this notion dude ger it's
called capacity which we already saw
earlier today okay so this is this is
the set up this is the idea of how we're
gonna go about this okay so this is how
it was defined earlier and well maybe it
was a little bit I can't remember if it
was a little bit less general than this
I can't remember if there was this alpha
involved but I'm gonna define it this
way where you have some polynomial in n
variables with non-negative coefficients
you have some alpha vector with
non-negative entries and I'll define the
alpha capacity of P to be this infimum
over the positive orphaned of value and
P divided by this sort of product of
powered variables okay
and so before I kind of get going on how
we're gonna use this I want to stop and
talk about a few properties that this
capacity has over my course of reading
services papers and trying to generalize
this sort of thing and you know figuring
out exactly what's going on with
capacity it sort of starts off as a very
mysterious thing I don't exactly right
you don't look at this and think to
yourself I'm going to be able to get
combinatorial lower bounds out of this
at least I don't but it turns out that
there are some common tutorial
properties of this and also certain
probabilistic and other things that sort
of enable you to by keeping track of
this of this quantity get get again
common tutorial bounds so let's just see
a couple of kind of the properties of
this that might suggest that something
like this is possible okay so the first
one I'm going to mention is just a sort
of combinatorial property which is maybe
at least to me is a little bit
surprising so this capacity right you
always have positive coefficients and
positive numbers you're plugging in so
it's always going to be a non-negative
thing okay but it turns out that it's
going to be positive precisely if alpha
is in the Newton polytope of P and if
you don't know what the Newton polytope
is you just kind of take vectors
associated to each monomial in the in
the support of your polynomial so if I
have like the term x1 squared x time
x2 then I look at a vector like 2 comma
1 comma and then maybe zeros for their
variables and for each term might make
one of these vectors and I look at the
convex hole of those vectors and I get
this poly tope associated to the
polynomial okay and the fact is that and
it's it's not hard to prove the fact is
that if alpha comes from this poly tope
you get something nonzero but but this
is if and only if and so the reason to
me why this is surprising is because
this says that capacity as a function of
alpha is is a dis is like a non
continuous function right if you go to
the boundary this poly tope is a closed
thing if you go to the boundary it will
be nonzero and as soon as you step off
the boundary it will be did I say what
did I say said yes this can see it's
it's not continuous right but not an
alpha at the boundary you know right if
you move past the boundary you go from a
positive number to zero yeah and the
polytope is continuous yes I agree with
that but the point is this this fact is
somehow like even though I don't know
this is a very analytic thing somehow
it's it's picking out the poly tope
which is if you think of alpha is coming
from from you know our plus to the N
right as soon as you leave the poly tope
it goes immediately to zero so this is
somehow I wasn't sort of expected to
meet just by looking at this another
sort of property is something that I'll
refer to as probabilistic and I'm gonna
I'm gonna use some words here associated
to probabilities that kind of give me
intuition for what's happening here even
though if maybe sometimes depending on
the Paula MS we look at they're not
going to make as much sense this is sort
of more like a giving me a sense of
what's going on so I'll say the the
explicit thing so the first thing to
notice is your capacity is always going
to be less than the evaluation of the
polynomial at 1 and this is easy to see
by just plugging in 1 here and it's an
emphasis
less than that but the point is you get
a quality if and only if your alpha
vector is this okay and the way you want
to think of this is the following so if
P were the probability generating
function of some distribution on finite
subsets of the numbers 1 through n okay
if so though the coefficient to a
certain monomial is the probability that
that monomial the the exponent of that
monomial is picked as a subset of 1
through n then this quantity is exactly
the marginal probabilities of that
distribution so the probability right
that it's a vector so the first Accord
entry of that vector is the probability
that if I draw a random set from this
vector the probability that X 1 like the
the first element of 1 through n will
show up in your set so somehow this has
some relation to certain right if if P
is can be represented as some you know
probability distribution this has some
probabilistic interpretation and more
generally I'm going to refer to this
quantity as the marginals but but maybe
always keep that in mind that it's
actually that even if P is not something
that necessarily it's easy to see that
it's some probability distribution for
instance for instance if P is you know
has terms which have the degree in
certain variables greater than 1 it's
not exactly clear what it's a
probability distribution on and in fact
the marginals might even be like greater
than 1 so maybe it doesn't make as much
sense but the intuition comes from this
this situation that I'm that I'm telling
you about when when P is the generating
polynomial for this distribution but in
any case then somehow it picks this out
it's maximized at that place this one
all kind of brush over it turns out that
something related to the capacity is the
convex conjugate of something related to
the polynomial so this is a function now
of alpha and this is related to certain
convexity properties that you get that
again nassif talked about earlier today
and and how you know you can use these
things under certain circumstances to to
maybe get some approximation algorithms
and the last one which I think is maybe
the most non-trivial of all of these is
which is very related to this and
actually the number two and number three
is somehow and again this she talked
about this earlier somehow the capacity
is something like this max relative
entropy right that's that's kind of what
the value of this is so if again we're
in this situation where P is some
probability distribution and I take the
supremum over all distributions with
these appropriate marginals then the
maximum I guess you could say negative
relative entropy is going to be exactly
the log of the capacity so I'm mainly
going to be using this property this
probabilistic property and what and what
comes next
that'll be the main thing that will that
will need but these are maybe some
general vague intuitions you might have
about capacity if you've never seen it
before or you know you're trying to
understand exactly what's going on
there's sort of and there's there's even
more kind of properties like this that
all kind of fit together
sorry about what class of peas
are these things true for our this
inclusive or can I always scale so it is
generating function so so this is these
things well the big versions of these
things are true for any polynomial with
positive coefficients you can scale
things to make right P of the all ones
just be one it's just that usually when
I'm talking about P being a probability
generating function I mean it in the
sense that it's a multi affine
polynomial like the degree of every
variable is at most one so that
literally a term is like the subset that
you're picking out with whatever
probability but but these things again
if you sort of just now define the
marginals to be this these things are
true for more general polynomials with
not just degree at most one in every
variable it's just and I guess there's
probably some probability distribution
you could associate to that where now
you're taking multi sets or something
like this yeah okay okay these are true
it's just maybe the interpretation is a
little more is a little less I don't
know it's the classic probabilistic
interpretation has to do with subsets of
this of this finite set if you consider
maybe multi sets and now like when
something shows up multiple times you
allow like the marginal probability to
be scaled in that situation then then
this is still true but you have to
define the marginals in that way which
is exactly what's going on here
okay so now then right maybe you have
some intuition of this thing called
capacity maybe you don't but the point
is now we're going to like try to
combine this capacity with real stable
polynomials and and see what we can get
so the the main theorem of Dermot's that
I'm that I'm going to talk about for
this method is the following right
if you have a polynomial P where the
degree and the number of variables are
the same and it's real stable and if you
know that its degree at most D in the K
variable then you get this bound okay
and and I'm not going to talk about the
proof of this all I'm gonna say is there
is a way like the original proof that he
did was very was very elementary
actually it was just kind of basic
calculus to get this proof I mean the
real the real power of this is coming up
with the right notion of capacity I mean
that that's the real thing here like you
can you can then go once you know what
to do
proving this becomes relatively
straightforward it's really coming up
with the right with the right quantity
to to keep track of but the point is
there is going to give a generalization
of this of this result which is
basically going to rely on this law
concavity property of real stable
polynomials so you should think of this
being related to log on cavity of real
stable poems by the way the very first
row to check it for that okay you
actually see your scaling
okay yeah I don't think I've seen that
that proof is it if you go to the Joss
paper in archives so if somebody like
the biography Google sure yeah sure
considered silk or there was the proof
was crazy just sooo cool sure yeah yeah
Wow yeah I mean the proof I know is is
much more elementary than Julie yes it's
good good yeah sure
there was it and there was a proof using
this was after after yeah yeah yeah
which again Newton's and Newton
inequalities another this is all sort of
related to some underlying log concavity
okay so how we're gonna use this well
it's pretty it's pretty straight simple
so the first thing I'll just mention
just so that the next line makes a
little more sense I'm hiding something a
little bit here with these ones so by
bold one I mean the all ones vector but
I only made it for the variables that
remain so there are n variables here so
this is gonna be length n but somehow
here I removed the K variables so I just
mean n minus 1 ones where the cake is
removed ok so the point is then by the
time that you spend all of your
derivatives on this polynomial okay
you're left with no more ones in this
capacity vector and you are just left
with the value that you get okay so you
have it the number of perfect matchings
is some a bunch of derivatives applied
to PG you you apply this bound inductor
inductively to each derivative that you
use okay and at the end of the day you
pick up n of these right and then with
this by the time because by the time
you're finished you have no more
derivatives so that's what you have
right if the number of perfect matchings
is lower bounded by this constant from
all n variables here times this last
capacity factor okay and the reason why
you can always you just it's going to be
this to the N is because of that D
stochasticity property right the D
regularity of the graph is the reason
why it's going to be a degree at most D
in X K and just as a quick illustration
of this which because this will sort of
come up later if I have some let me
write down some very basic graph here ok
and if I write down then the matrix
associated to this and then I write down
the polynomial
I'm going to write it in this sort of
matrix form
all right so the idea is then what is
going to be the degree so this is a you
know homogeneous polynomial degree three
and three variables
what's going to be to the degree of the
ice variable well let's look at x2 for
instance it's going to be the number of
times x2 shows up in each of these terms
so in this case it's going to be two but
in fact the degree is actually just
going to be the column sum or more
generally the number of nonzero entries
in each column okay so this is another
again this is something surprising to me
because I think of capacity as some
analytic concept maybe a priori and yet
somehow like some kind of information
about non number of nonzero entries is
coming into this analytic bound right so
to me number of nonzero entries is
something pretty combinatorial this is
something pretty analytic it's maybe a
little bit surprising that it would come
into play like this in my opinion but
the way it comes into play is precisely
ending the degree so we do this and then
the last thing we need to do is try to
approximate or at least compute this and
what we have in this case is something
really nice we can compute these
marginals exactly and it it the the d
stochasticity basically just implies
that these marginals is just the is just
the all ones vector and again it doesn't
make sense somehow that marginals would
all be one right doesn't that mean that
like the probability of everything is is
100% again this is some generalized
marginals the fact that we don't have
something that is multi affine here
means that this makes more sense so this
we can compute exactly based on this D
regularity and so then we just plug in
one to get the capacity
for me it's easier to let down but in
this form it's much sharp because the
degrees are children getting yes yes if
you can't put it right down then the
quality the texture you get something
which is sharp okay so I mean yeah I
guess in general I think the point that
my own is making here is that you can
keep track somehow of the the degree of
each variable but you know that say
after I apply a whole bunch of these
derivatives it's going to drop the
homogeneity rate down and if that gets
below D then I can use that number
instead of D here it and even better so
so if I know keeping track of more
degree information and doing some other
things you can get sharper bounce than
this this is maybe more just a just a
explanation of what we're planning to do
for this next application
okay so let me let me just recap here a
little bit so the idea was we started
off with some polynomial we could
compute its capacity easily
we had some linear operators we applied
we knew how that changed the capacity
and at the end of the day we got
something that we wanted to bound okay
so the part that I was able to
generalize here is right somehow Garba
this theorem was for a very specific
differential operator just this one
which then had a very very nice
implications okay later
nema and Shayan if I don't know if
they're here proved something more
general for a huge class of differential
operators in fact they proved a bound
for all differential operators it turned
out not to be quite the tightest thing
you could get so they would have they
have some result like this except this
now becomes certain stability preserving
differential operator okay and this
becomes something else but it turns out
that basically you can generalize this
to any roughly speaking any real
stability preserver okay and that is
this result okay so T is some I'm going
to call non degenerate real stability
preserver and you have these vectors
then there's some constant that is going
to bound the capacity of what like bound
what the capacity of what you get when
you apply this operator T to P and this
is this you're gonna get some Universal
K for any real stable P and this K is
going to be tight I'm not going to write
it down here but it has some explicit
formula in terms of alpha and beta and
in terms of if you're familiar with this
the the virtue of
Rondon characterization it's also in
terms of the capacity of the symbol of T
okay and by non degenerate I just mean
that your symbol is real stable so you
can talk about this if you don't then
just there's some constant that we have
a formula for
so the way that I typically interpret
this is that this is some kind of
analytics tension of that
characterization the idea being that
right if you have some operator key
which preserves real stability not only
does it preserve real stability but also
it preserves capacity right that's one
maybe one way you could say this there's
some bound on a multiplicative bound on
how much capacity can go down right and
this this fact is exactly the fact we
used or the herbage used on in the proof
of the previous theorem right we
successfully use this property and this
gave us some some lower bound so that's
how I think of this and it turns out
also this is some generalization of an
inner product lower bound for real
stable polynomials like I said this is
due to Nima and Shayan I'm not gonna
talk too much about this but again the
point is that that lower bound is you do
some big inductive process to get down
to some really basic base case you use
the strongly Rayleigh inequalities which
you should think of as multivariate log
and cavity to prove this lower bound
that somehow this result is some you
know big generalization of that base
case so again this is all relying on
these logs and cavity properties of real
simple polynomials in a really strong
way yes you just like from the fact that
the polynomial is real stable so again
what is the question I don't know if you
are the capacity of a polynomial but
they assume that it is real stable is
that some additional nice there is
something so if you will go to Greece to
the definition of capacity
yes so imagine you have here alpha so a
cool one okay and you what you do
instead of writing this thing and few
more mobile positive numbers take
absolutely no polynomial infimum when
real parts on the positive okay then
it's like complex capacity and that what
did you will be just responsible for
real stability it's happened to be that
in the real stable case that complex
definition is equal to this one in
general they're not equal
so again you extend this definition
considering taking absolute value and is
thank you if you move over a real hot
spot okay you get some quantity sure you
could it is zero you don't care but if
this quantity is positive means that
your polynomial is like it couldn't been
zero anywhere if it's you don't assume
that the coefficients on sure yeah yeah
complexity becomes kind of a measure of
stability
sure and it's happened to be the in
stable case if you know that this number
is positive then the serially computed
in general negative so this is one of
the peculiar situation yes so the idea
the idea basically is you can extend
under certain circumstances you can take
this in to be over a whole half plane
and then you put absolute values around
this and if this is if your polynomial
start off being stable then this ends up
being this ends up being equal to the
original capacity and in fact it being
on zero is a certificate that it is
stable so that's that that's the idea
there a question about you so there's
nothing that saying what alpha and beta
are with respect each other so does this
say there bumps on both directions so so
alpha and beta can be anything but so
I'm hiding a lot of things here if you
pick some alphas and betas that you
expect to be like combinatorially
problematic
this cave will just end up being zero so
so the point is somehow you you you will
always get there's a there's an explicit
formula okay you'll always get something
it's just if you pick alpha and beta to
be kind of problematic it's just gonna
be zero because that is that is the
tightest constant for that for those
comp that that pair so it comes out in
the in the expression of K but and you
can reverse them again it just it sort
of depends on your T and which alpha and
beta is you're looking at what exactly
is gonna happen okay so getting back to
this again I'm just gonna make a few
comments about this which I'm not gonna
have time to go through but like I said
oh I already said this this is very
related to login cavity and another
thing there's this there's this paper of
Damien and and the sheath from a couple
years ago that basically shows that the
expression that you get in this lower
bound is sort of if after some kind of
change of variables and taking logs and
things like this this is exactly the the
Beth approximation okay and the point is
they they use this to show that if if
you have a partition function where the
polynomials involved are real stable
then you actually get that the Beth
approximation is in fact a lower bound
for for the actual partition function
and the way they do this is they
transfer the Beth approximation into
this question about inner product lower
bounds and then they use this result of
nema and Shayan to show that this in
fact is a lower bound so again I haven't
give this inner product bound here I
just talked about some generalization of
it but somehow this is also generalizing
this somehow so I don't know I don't
actually know exactly but if anyone has
any maybe intuition about that if
they've seen this stuff that I'm talking
about I'd be interested to hear about it
okay so let's move on then so I think I
have about what's the time but six
minutes is there
yeah seven okay great okay okay so let
me just then quickly talk about how
exactly we're gonna apply this to
counting in particular this kind of
lower bounding thing but again a lot of
this stuff can be used for approximation
so let me just go through this so we're
going to take that plan we used before
and now we're going to just generalize
it with respect to this result I just
gave so we're gonna start with some
stable polynomial that somehow encodes
the object we care about and you know
this extra added fact that we can
compute capacity for it very easily okay
so we have the starting point we apply
some operators which preserve stability
and now we can use much more general
things here and we can determine from
this constant K exactly how the capacity
changes under this operation and at the
end you know fingers crossed we're gonna
get something back which is now just a
constant polynomial just to some kind of
constant that's exactly the thing we
wanted to we wanted to bound okay so
this is exactly what we did before but
now we have a much more options for that
for the type of operator we can use and
you know if you're approximating you
might want an upper bound as well
there's a sort of result in this
direction in this paper that I refer to
but I'm just mainly interested in the
lower bounds so now we're going to shift
to this slightly more general situation
which this is the situation that Peter
safari considers so let's suppose now we
have this by regular bipartite graph
okay we're now the by partitions are
different sizes and the regularities are
also gonna be different right it's three
regular from the top two from the bottom
okay and we write down the matrix in the
exact same way rows correspond to the
top columns to this to the bottom so we
now have a rectangular matrix okay and
we can do similar things except maybe
you know maybe we want to count in
perfect matchings now so let's say I
want to count the number of three
matchings well let me write one down
there's a three matching and what a
three matching is going to look like
here is a collection of three rows and
columns that contain exactly one one
okay so more generally right if we
generalize the fact that the permanent
counted perfect
matchings right the number of K matches
then is gonna be the number of K sub
permanence so you take all you know K by
K sub matrices and you compute the
permanent of each of those and you sum
them all up and another generalization
of what we got for D regularity is the
fact that now right if I'm I'm a be
regular it means my my row sums are
gonna be a my column sums are gonna be B
so it's looking like we can probably
generalize this whole thing but let's
see what happens so we can write this
polynomial down in the same way before
okay so I'm going to switch gears really
quick because I'm gonna I'm going to
talk about exactly what Peter obtains
for this and then I'm gonna sort of go
back to this picture so this is the type
of thing we want to count and what he
gets is this sort of bound
I'm unfortunately I'm not going to talk
about it very much at all but I will
just give you some intuition about it so
this H is some entropy function for some
by regular infinite by regular treat PK
is something that I'm not going to be
able to talk about I actually have very
little intuition for it so just this is
some extra factor that maybe that maybe
comes out okay but but the point is why
you would expect this entropy function
to show up is basically this intuition
so you have this you you have this
bipartite graph you want to count
matchings on it and the intuition comes
from the following sort of idea that
small odd cycles in the graph produced
less matchings and even small even
cycles in the graph produced more
matches okay
and if we're if we're inviting the
bipartite case you don't have any odd
cycles so we can sort of get rid of that
but then as soon as we don't have any
odd cycles sort of the worst case
situation is that you know we have no
small even cycles all right if we have
no even cycles at all then somehow we
you know intuitively should have the
least number of matchings possible okay
and so somehow the worst case is if
we're going to lower bound something
that's sort of like a tree and maybe
this is some general idea as to why
you'd expect something like the infinite
by regular tree to appear in the lower
bound okay I'm not I'm gonna sort of
just brush over that I only have a few
minutes here but that's kind of the
intuition for this bound okay and it
turns out this bound translates into if
you
do a bunch of algebra and computations
you get something that looks a lot like
Shrivers bound but it just it's a lot
more complicated there's like you know a
a a n to the power a n times some be
something to the power whatever
multiplied by a lot of things from this
PK you get some like in this Bernoulli
thing you get some n choose K okay I'm
not I'm not gonna write down the actual
expression here but you get some
complicated algebraic thing you can
convert from this and this is the sort
of thing then that looks like something
you know something like Shrivers bound
it looks like something you could get
out of this capacity method okay not as
clear okay so let's try to emulate then
what we did before okay so we had this
polynomial okay we we had the perfect
matchings we're this big differential
operator but now we have to do something
a little more complicated we have to
write this is somehow what were we gonna
do we're gonna take Kate derivatives and
we're going to take all possible
combinations of Kate derivatives so you
out of one through n you pick K all
possible K things you take those
derivatives those case excessive
derivatives and then you sum up all
those possible things the problem is now
right let's suppose I'm in this
situation and I'm taking to write my K
is to write maybe I take derivatives
respect to x1 and this I take derivative
respect to X 3 in this something like
this and I'm left with some linear right
if K is less than n I'm going to be left
with some homogeneous polynomial at the
end of this so plugging in 0 is apt all
right we can't plug in 0 that's gonna be
a big problem it just gonna zero out
everything so maybe we plug in something
else maybe we plug in 1 but I I don't
you know maybe a priori it isn't why are
we plugging in 1 ok well we sort of get
lucky in this case since we have
regularity once we apply a bunch of
derivatives we're going to be left with
some big sum of products of linear 's
and we know that each of those Linear's
have have terms that sum to a right we
had this a regularity property okay so
we're just this applying this to PG is
just going to give us the number of K
matchings times some extra factor that
comes from the fact that we had to plug
in 1 ok but the note here is that
already we're requiring regularity of
the graph before just writing this down
for any for any matrix was computing the
permanent
okay now if we want to compute a bunch
of sub permanence right we we at least
to write something on explicit we
already need some kind of regularity
property okay yeah for something
explicit this is the formula which was
used in consistency so it's instead of
everything kept one you can relate to
zero but they could have one minus
partial derivative sure it's exactly was
there an expression for which a
polynomial in that case instead of
linear form suppose they owned was
determinant oh right yeah yeah I guess
I've never I have to have to think about
that that was nobody here put a
conjecture first an unproved using
romantics I think was different
but oh they all related I mean that it
once he regularly I mean this is the
natural thing to do so I would imagine
this was done before yeah
anyway the point is then we can
basically apply the same exact thing we
have some stochasticity properties so we
compute these marginals they turn out to
be some constant thing times one so we
can just plug in one we get this we have
our polynomial for which capacities easy
to compute we now have this thing which
turns out to be that one of these non
degenerate real stability preservers
okay this is something like a polarized
kate derivative so we can apply the
theorem to it and we get some against
some specific k value and then we we we
already saw that this discounts gay
matching so it has all the pieces we
want and you just put this together and
you get everything you want and i will
say i don't have it really any time left
so i'm gonna make one last comment about
this okay i'm gonna put a bunch of stuff
here don't you can read this if you want
while i'm telling this quick story but
the most maybe one of the more
interesting things about this is this
proof doesn't really require the correct
intuitions i gave you these intuitions
about about counting matchings and and
when i you know when I originally wrote
down that theory
that I showed you I sort of emailed
Gurewitz because I thought he would be
the one who'd be most interested in that
result and I said do you like what do
you think this can be applied to and he
basically said oh I think you should be
able to reprove Jaguar he's bound so I
took his bound I sort of turned it into
some algebra I then kind of just plugged
it in and it gave me exactly the right
thing and I and honestly I had no
intuitions about about the matching so
you can either think of this as
something cool in the fact that like I
didn't have the right intuitions and yet
I was able to prove this like nice bound
that really oh that was all right that
was kind of the tightest thing we had up
until that point or you can think of
this as sort of like bad that you know
someone who didn't have the right
intuitions was able to do something I
don't know it depends on your on your
philosophy I guess good well yeah well
yeah any case so it depends on your
persuasion I guess but I'll just say
anyway that that's sort of that's sort
of how this came about and that's that's
kind of all I have these are further of
questions but but I don't know they have
time to talk about
[Applause]
questions remarks so the proof I mean
yeah the proof is kind of right I broke
the proof of the Wagar it said things
down into this kind of induction we
don't need to use induction here because
we just have a single operator but
that's all so it made it more
complicated right we needed some way
that we didn't need to use this
induction on the differential operator
so somehow but we have all the pieces
you have the the polynomial that
represents the thing we that represents
our object and for which capacities easy
to compute we have this differential
operator we know by the theorem exactly
how it changes the capacity and then
after you apply it you get some value
that's exactly the thing you wanted to
count and so that's that you get a bound
by just putting the pieces together
I mean a reason why it should not be
possible I actually you can do something
but but at the moment it's not that it's
not amenable you can get capacities
developable capacity itself is upper
bound but you can play a little bigger
there no it's probably requires more
work
there's also potentially something you
can do where that one of these inner
product bounds so the you you have some
expression that's basically of this form
you have some like P Q is greater than
equal to some constant times capacity P
times capacity Q this is roughly
speaking what the what this inner
product found looks like and there's a
way basically where you can set up these
P and Q to sort of like this inner
product is some coefficient wise product
and so the idea is maybe if all your
coefficients are 1 and and you do this
you're getting and you do some inner
product you're getting some sum of
something but then there's a way to in
the capacity also to put the sum so you
get somehow like a sum over here and a
squared sum over here and so then
whenever you divide out by one of them
you get an upper bound so that so
there's some maybe way to do is I've
never seen
a way to get something that's that great
out of this you won't get no no I
wouldn't think so you so you can get
some things but it looks like they at
least in my from what I've tried it
doesn't look like you can get something
like that's better than what we know
so you say that your constant so sharp
yes so they are sharp
if you based on the individual degree of
each variable right which is which is
something you might expect because in
your characterization right you get a
different one based on individual
degrees his conjecture is is based on
knowing just the total degree and not
having to take into account individual
degrees that's the reason why you don't
get the constant so if lambda is the
vector of degrees of your variables
the constant is basically something
along these lines
where this is like you know you get more
variables here so this is alpha and some
of the variables beta on the other ones
and then this is a constant that comes
out of the inner product that I can make
a call so what is what this component is
enough legs is that this arguments okay
you can get those things they lead to
results like sharp there is one weakness
and shadows things which echoes which I
kind of slightly over get the two K you
don't get one derived in from shop okay
my confusion about this is
generalization of under one and you
would not prove it using cervixes okay
so again so you need that you need to
combine those two things which worked
miraculously for then result we change
this constant capacity so again this is
things which would prove you like
shriver things which is the one give you
one together without the extra
improvement again this is the and
actually stated some kind of conjecture
here which is explained but listen this
is the essence
two other questions or remarks okay so
look just one month what is important so
it's very beautified look I when I had
this that when they proved the global
bond on the regular case which was
called as treatment to over much in
contempt okay so I thought I thought
that there is okay I hope that there is
a stable proof for that okay
[Laughter]
[Applause]